nos dicen el pentágono a prima b prima s
prima de prima prima que es justo este
que tengo de color rosa por aquí es la
imagen del pentágono abs de m que es
este que tengo de color azul después de
aplicar una potencia cuál es la razón de
potencia y bueno tampoco nos dan el
centro de la potencia pero para obtener
la razón de la potencia que es lo que
estamos buscando simplemente tienes que
recordar que cuando haces una potencia
las distancias entre dos puntos
correspondientes cambian de acuerdo con
la razón de montesa por ejemplo aquí
podemos ver que entre el punto a y el
punto b
tenemos 246 unidades en este caso es
nuestro cambio en james y nos da una
distancia de 6 unidades
y ahora qué pasa con el lado
correspondiente a primavera bueno es
este de aquí observan a primavera priman
sólo miden dos unidades por lo tanto
aquí tenemos dos unidades este es mi
cambio y puedes ver que pasamos de un
lado de seis unidades a otro de dos
unidades
por lo tanto tuviste que multiplicar el
seis por un tercio para obtener dos
ahora sí podemos decir que nuestra razón
de potencia en este caso será de un
tercio ok
tercio puede que digas que en este caso
es bastante sencillo porque es muy clara
la distancia que hay entre ahí ven cómo
podemos encontrar la razón de murcia si
no tenemos un segmento vertical u
horizontal en nuestra figura bueno una
forma de obtenerla es fijarnos en los
cambios en x y en yen de un punto a otro
por ejemplo si queremos saber la
distancia que hay entre el punto am y el
punto m puedes observar que nuestro
cambio en game es de 3 unidades hacia
abajo es decir menos 3 y nuestro cambio
en x es de 3 unidades hacia la derecha
es decir 3 y puedes ver que entre a
primaria prima nuestro cambio en kiev es
de una unidad hacia abajo es decir menos
1 y nuestro cambio en x es de una unidad
hacia la derecha y observa menos 1 es un
tercio de menos 3 y 1 es un tercio de 3
así que una vez más
una razón de potencia de un tercio bien
hagamos otro ejemplo así que déjenme
quitar este de aquí y ahora vamos a
trabajar con este de acá el pentágono a
prima de prima se prima de prima y prima
que observa no nos dan ese pentágono
pero dicen es la imagen del pentágono a
bs de m que es este pentágono de azul
después de aplicar una potencia con una
razón de 5 medios aquí si me dan la
razón de noticia cual es la longitud del
segmento a prima y prima
insisto no nos da la figura a primera b
primera se prima de primer y prima de
modo que como podemos encontrar la
longitud del segmento a prima y prima de
encargo que pausa es el vídeo e intente
resolverlo
ok la clave es que nos dan la razón de
modestia porque cuando nos dicen que la
razón de potencia es de 5 medios
significa que los lados correspondientes
cambian con este factor de 5 medios así
que para encontrar la longitud del
segmento a prima y prima puedes pensar
en que es la imagen del segmento a en
después de aplicarle la potencia y se
observa la longitud del segmento
es de 2 unidades entonces puedo
escribirlo el segmento
tiene como longitud dos unidades y por
lo tanto la longitud del lado a prima y
prima va a ser igual a la longitud de
este segmento en que son dos unidades
por la razón de potencia es decir por
cinco medios esta es mi razón de
potencia que es justo lo que me dice el
problema y por supuesto dos por cinco
medios son cinco unidades así que el
segmento a prima o prima tiene una
longitud de cinco unidades y en este
caso no era necesario dibujar el
pentágono a primavera prima se prima de
prima prima de yum
no me tanto de la información completa
porque podría dibujar por aquí una
versión con una escala de cinco medios
de abs de m pero para encontrar la
imagen de la noticia necesito también el
centro de la potencia
lo que sí sabemos es que la longitud de
los lados correspondientes deben escalar
sé por un factor de 5 medios es decir
por la razón de potencia para obtener
los lados de la imagen ok con esto en
mente hagamos otro ejemplo más ni para
eso déjame quitar este de aquí y ahora
tengo estética el triángulo a prima de
prima se prima que es este que tengo de
color rosa es la imagen del triángulo a
abc después de aplicar una potencia con
una razón de 2 esto es importante
cuál es la longitud del segmento ave
insisto esta vez no nos dan el triángulo
a abc lo único que tenemos es la imagen
a prima de primera se prima así que con
esto como podemos encontrar la longitud
del segmento abc1 de encargo que pausa
es el vídeo e intente resolverlo
bueno observa si tenemos la longitud del
segmento ave ya esto lo multiplicamos
por la razón de motes ya que en este
caso es 2 por el factor de escala la
razón de murcia que es 2 voy a obtener
la imagen que es a prima de prima es
decir la longitud de la imagen es igual
al factor de escala oa la razón de
murcia por la longitud del segmento
original entonces cuál es la longitud de
ave bueno es muy fácil de encontrar si
sabemos que la longitud de la primavera
prima es de 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 ok
esta longitud de aquí es de 8 unidades
entonces voy a obtener que dos veces la
longitud del segmento
avn que es lo que busco es igual a 8 o
dicho de otra manera la longitud del
segmento
es igual a sí divido entre dos de ambos
lados voy a obtener 4 así que ya con
esto hemos acabado nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo